hi there welcome to simon says where you
ask questions
and i answer them let's take a look at
the first one it's from molina
molina asks are there times where you
shouldn't be optimistic
no you should always be optimistic
but it's sometimes difficult to be
optimistic but the striving should
always be to be optimistic i can't think
of a reason why we wouldn't want to be
optimistic
again optimism is different from blind
positivity it doesn't mean it's the
denial of difficult times
it's not naive we can believe that we're
in a dark tunnel but we can still stay
focused on the light at the end of the
tunnel that's what optimism is
it's the belief that the future is
bright okay
next question how do you do
how do you deal with career jealousy
asks eric well if you're jealous of
other people's careers
that probably means that something's
happening in your life that is tickling
some sort of insecurity so if you find
yourself getting angry or jealous
at somebody else's good fortune the
question is
is what what nerve is it touching what
insecurity do i need to address
also if we take an infinite mindset it
doesn't really matter what anybody else
is doing i understand it's difficult i
suffer from it
as well we see people who are younger
than us and making more money than us
it touches a nerve it makes us feel
insecure about where we are in this
current state
but the hard work is to focus on
ourselves focus where we can
improve and worry about our careers not
about their careers
okay lee asks
where does the desire to learn come from
well i think it's innate i think that
those that have a desire to learn
um believe that there is more to learn
that they don't know everything
regardless of how much success they have
regardless
how old they are regardless how wise
they are they just believe there's more
to learn there's an innate curiosity
that there's more
out there that they don't know so can we
teach people to want to learn more
that's a different question i i mean the
optis
the optimist in me says yes but uh but
yeah
it's the belief that there's always more
out there okay next one
is there room for emotions in the
workplace
um is there a way not to have emotions
in the workplace
i mean have you ever been jealous have
you ever been insecure have you ever
been
angry have you ever been sad have you
ever been frustrated has your boss ever
said anything to you mate that made you
feel like they're wonderful or they're
horrible
congratulations you're human you have
emotions for people who think that there
aren't
emotions in the workplace then you're
not human i know senior senior senior
senior executives
who make decisions because they're
afraid that the ceo might yell at them
that's called emotions the challenge is
to be emotionally professional
the that we cannot come to work because
we're having a
a bad day or something happened in our
personal lives and just sit there with
our arms folded and be all grumpy and
one-word
answers in a meeting that's emotionally
unprofessional
so there's absolutely a role a role for
emotional professionalism but there's no
eliminating
emotions okay uh
gene asks how do you create work-life
balance
with a remote job it's really hard these
days
when our office is our kitchen or our
living room
and it's about drawing a fine line in
the sand now
for better for worse we've been
struggling with this for a long time
you know the promise of smartphones was
that we could leave the office
it didn't happen we took the office with
us and so we've had to learn the
strategies of disconnecting
um i think it's the same here you need
to you need to create lines in the sand
so a certain time
work stops what i find works for me is
to physically close the computer
i don't just leave it open and up i
physically close the computer
sometimes even put it away work is over
if we leave it out we can't help
ourselves but to keep checking it same
goes with our phones
leave the phone with the computer
physically put them away
and focus on family or yourself
next question okay uh
what if the thing you love to do
isn't the thing you're best at asks
michaela
that's okay as long as you derive joy
from it the tricky thing
is if you're really good at something
you hate because then you find yourself
in a job
getting paid for something you don't
want to do
if you're if the thing you love to do is
something you're best at
i guess if you keep doing at it you'll
get better at it most things improve
with practice so if you love doing it
do more you know you love it keep doing
it
okay that one hit me in the face um ari
asks
when do we need to be selfish i think
the time we need to be
selfish is when we're doing things that
are hurting us
so for example if we find ourselves
never resting and working and working
and working and working and working
now you can be selfish if you find
yourself constantly saying yes to things
or being there for somebody else to the
point where you're making yourself sick
you need to be selfish i don't believe
in the idea
of of martyrdom i don't believe in the
idea that you're constantly constantly
constantly giving to others to the point
where you destroy yourself
it's about finding the right balance
it's impossible it's art more than
science
but it's what it means to be human
unfortunately sometimes we have to be
selfish which means saying no
the funny thing that i've learned is
that saying no
is actually better than saying yes and
then either not showing up fully or not
being able to be there for somebody else
in other words disappointing someone
that we thought we could be there for
it's actually better to just say no and
i've learned to say no to friends
and say let me get it get to you at
another time
or in work same thing and it's amazing
people are actually more patient and
willing to work with me
so do we when do we need to be selfish
when you find yourself hurting yourself
all right can you be a good leader
but a bad person asks ellie
uh depends how you define
bad person but no i don't think you can
because inherent to being a good leader
is to have concern for other people
and inherent to being a bad person in my
mind is having no concern for other
people
uh so can you be a good leader
and a bad person no i think you have to
have empathy you have to have patience
a good leader wants to see those around
them rise a bad person
puts themselves first wants to see
themselves rise sometimes at the expense
of others
however being a good person can help you
learn to be a better person
sorry being a good leader can help you
learn to be a better person
um what do you do when your employees
won't listen
or how do you make people listen asks
chelsea oh
chelsea okay what do you do when your
employees won't listen
is it your employees or is it the way
you're speaking to them
there's a wonderful little book called
how to talk to kids so kids will listen
and listen so kids will talk
yes it's a parenting book it's also a
brilliant leadership book
i highly recommend checking it out
chelsea
very often i find that if somebody won't
listen i take a look at myself first and
try different strategies
i've even asked other people to deliver
the message for me because sometimes
it's a personality thing
sometimes the way i communicate is
better received by some people
and the way somebody i work with
communicates is better received by
others
so it's about trying different
strategies um
also empathy um maybe they won't listen
because there's something
going on in their lives that you're
ignoring maybe they're under a certain
kind of stress that
you're just not paying attention to so
going up to them and saying
hey i've been trying to connect with you
and i'm really struggling
and so i just wanted to find out are you
okay what's going on
that's a great way to get people to
start to hear
and for you to hear them so how you get
people to listen probably start
listening to them
okay valerie wants to know what do you
do
when you feel overqualified for a role
ask for more responsibility if you feel
overqualified
um you can ask do more you can also
offer to help others take on more
responsibility even
informally you said feel overqualified
because
that's really interesting versus
actually being overqualified
you can ask the person you work for and
say i think i'm capable of taking on
more
can you take a risk on me can you give
me something more and let me see if i
can do it
and you'll discover very quickly whether
you feel overqualified or if you
actually
are overqualified yes that is a plane
flying over this is live guys this is
live
okay uh how can i work on myself
while i'm self-isolated uh ask amani
um well the good news is self-work uh
doesn't require us to be out in the open
there's many ways
for self-work one is reading watching
talks
getting strategies but you can also call
people and have zoom calls
and get coaching and ask advice from
friends and help ask them to point
things out to you the most important
thing is you can't really do self
work completely by yourself it's kind of
ironic when people say you need to work
on yourself it's not like you go off
into the himalayas and lock yourself
in a cave and you work on yourself i
hear this in relationships all the time
people you know break up because
my partner needs to work on themselves
well guess what the best way to work on
yourself is actually in a partnership
whether it's romantic or friendship or
otherwise so at least find a friend who
wants to go on the journey with you
and the best way to do self-help is
actually um
that you commit to helping someone who's
actually struggling
with the same things as you in other
words you agree to help each other um
i always think that doing self-work is
actually a team sport
ironically all right um
why do we chase profit why is money and
the accumulation and the accumulation of
it
a top priority asks alan well partially
it's our society
our society has defined success by
your car your house your bank account
it's unfortunate it's just the way we've
gone it doesn't have to be that way
but it is we chase profit also because
that's how
uh we're judged we're judge and our
companies very often by how much we
produce by how much we
bring in we need to change the incentive
structures
um we need to judge people by helpful
how helpful they are to others
are they good team members we need to
find better balances in our society
and we probably all need to learn to be
a little more zen buddhist
and learn to disconnect ourselves from
the material and find joy
and happiness in our friends and the
things that we do in the experiences
that we have
not just the stuff that we have so i
think it just takes practice
and uh and a little change in our
society which then begs the question how
do we change our society
change starts at home okay is college a
waste of time in today's world
asks matthew no it's not i know there's
a whole movement against college
and one of the reasons there's a
movement against college comes from
people who've
done extremely well either while they
were in college and dropped out
mark zuckerberg mark zuckerberg or
had good fortune and didn't need the
college and so they stand up and say you
don't need college i didn't need college
well that's true some people don't need
it but there's more to college than
simply the
subjects that we learn do we need the
subjects in college
not really most of the stuff we'll study
in college we won't need in future
in our future and it won't help us be
successful but we're learning more than
that in school
we're learning how to interact with
other people for
many of us it's the first time we we've
left home we're learning to
fend for ourselves do our own laundry
get a job provide for ourselves
budget our money that's a new one for
many people
they're living in dorms they're learning
to interact
they're learning independence they're
learning self-reliance it's also the
first time in a classroom
where your professors will expect you to
disagree in high school
largely you do as you're told you take
the test and that's it in college it's
about discussion and it's about
disagreement and sometimes there are no
right answers
so one of the things you'll learn is how
to disagree how to form an argument
there's
so much more that you learn in college
that will help you in
the rest of your life that have nothing
to do with the subjects
that you're going to learn in other
words choose your classes based on the
quality of your professors
not based on how easy the classes are or
sometimes even just what the subject is
yes college still has value in our lives
um elias ask what's more important
depth of knowledge or breadth of
knowledge depends what you want to do
with it
context matters it's it's there's no
such thing a right or wrong or good or
bad here
if you want to do a job that requires
breadth of knowledge well then that's
more important
if you're doing a job that requires
depth of knowledge well that's more
important there is literally no right
answer here
what i would recommend is play to your
strengths most people have
a natural leaning i'm a generalist i
don't necessarily have
depth of knowledge in one particular
thing but i'm pretty
good at taking bits and pieces from all
over the place so guess what i've done
i've pointed my career in a direction
where breadth of knowledge is actually a
little more helpful
but if it's a depth of knowledge thing
where i have to go deep into the numbers
and deep into the studies and all that
i fall apart so if you have a natural
leaning
try and point yourself to a job or a
career that actually helps you work to
your natural strengths
thanks very much for all your questions
thanks for joining me on simon says the
place where you ask the questions and i
answer them and please send more and
we'll do another one of these thanks
very much and see you soon
[Music]
you